foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
welcome
just a few technical difficulties but we
work through
monday morning
or afternoon depending on where you are
you know what time it is noon eastern 11
central nine pacific
you are here two hours every single
weekday so am i
on youtube twitter and twitch
we had just a a a little bit of a
technical difficulty with a camera here
i don't know my camera wasn't working so
i had to restart and get going but we're
here it's monday and they have not
passed the pac act
still uh these republicans these vile
creatures i'm gonna give you evidence
video evidence
today
why these despicable pieces of [ __ ] need
to be voted out every last single one of
them not just in the senate not just in
the house but in state legislators
governors all the way down to the
goddamn dog catcher for crying out loud
we have to mobilize we have to do the
thing that democracies do
which is democracy you know like engage
in the ballot
not just mark the ballot but have
strategic outrage to go out there and to
make sure
to make sure that democracy is done and
stop infighting enough of this nonsense
the democrats aren't doing this this is
ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous
that's right i said it i'll shake my
finger at anyone
who is hurting democracy by blaming my
blaming the people who are actually
doing the thing which is policy
actually doing the thing that the
american people want
and yeah there's a few on the fringe
a few democrats that aren't doing it
but it is not the reason why our country
can't get [ __ ] done the reason why our
country can't get [ __ ] done is because
we have a bunch of kid diddling [ __ ]
traitors out there
who continue to want our country to be a
fascist state
plain and
simple
there's not much more i can say about it
than that that's just exactly what they
want they do not
want us to be a democracy
i have more proof for you that
on and on and on with this abortion
oh all's we have to do is overturn roe v
wade and everything will be great yeah
my ass
my [ __ ] ass
this has only opened the door to them
wanting to take away the rest of women's
rights
the west the rest of parental rights
the rest of anyone's rights for that
matter right the contraception right to
vote
they're ready they're ready folks they
are ready for their fascist state
i have proof of it and it's not it's not
even that long of a clip
in west virginia
some [ __ ] white dudes standing up
talking about
little girls being raped and how it's a
romantic thing i'm not [ __ ] you i'm
not kidding you
i would not [ __ ] you you're my favorite
turd this is ridiculous
that we have to continue to do this
there's veterans sitting outside the
capitol in the [ __ ] rain
waiting for these republican senators to
get off their ass and do what they did
just weeks ago and vote for the pac act
so that these veterans can receive the
[ __ ] health care that they need
forget about for i mean we we are well
over
the earned hurdle here they earned it a
long time ago
and pat toomey that [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
i mean
ted cruz is the corn
in the pat toomey turd to be quite
honest with you
it's known that ted cruz is a [ __ ]
vile piece of garbage but pat toomey
wanting to make sure that this funding
stops that's what he's wanting with his
amendment this is all a big [ __ ] lie
from every single [ __ ] traitor that
there is and it's enough of not calling
them [ __ ] traitors it's enough of it
normalizing this [ __ ] the media having
these people on and let them just
[ __ ] lie
and not calling them on it it's enough
of this garbage
[ __ ] garbage flooding means fascists
do whatever they want whenever they want
in the media [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
if you're gonna lie then fine you don't
get to be on here to spread your [ __ ]
lies and when you are on your spreading
your [ __ ] lies then we call you out
to your goddamn face it's enough
enough of pat toomey's lying acting like
somehow democrats the only reason why
that the republicans didn't vote is
because pat toomey didn't get his way
and they got butt hurt they got butt
hurt because manchin voted on some
climate act on a little piece
in the chips bill
and he he [ __ ] he
he did a deal with schumer and it pissed
him off
because republicans know something about
joe manchin joe manchin has to appease
republican voters because he is the
senator from west virginia
he has to appease republican voters
republicans know that
and they thought this was going to be a
victory for them they really did they
were [ __ ] pounding fist on the floor
of the senate
all excited about killing this pact act
until toomey got his way
because that's really what what they're
waiting for here
they're waiting for the tumi amendment
to be part of this pac deck when they
tell you the democrats changed this bill
what they mean is we want to change this
bill
it's always projection with these
[ __ ] always 100 percent full
stop almost every single goddamn time
all the way
balls deep into the projection
that's why when you hear them say
something so vile you're like jesus
christ are they confessing
because for them to lie the democrats
change this bill
it's the projection that they want to
change the bill they want to change the
funding from mandatory to discretionary
so they can rob the funding
and pat toomey wants to put a cap on it
he wants to make sure that we don't
spend over a certain amount because [ __ ]
those veterans even [ __ ] them don't need
them they get this amount of money and
that's it
i mean they're not an active war these
people are sick they can't fight for us
so [ __ ] them we don't like them that's
pat toomey's thought process they're not
actual soldiers like active they can't
even fight what the [ __ ] are we giving
them money for
pat toomey and the republicans say
the other thing that he wants to do is
he wants to make sure that this that
this funding ends in 10 years
so in 10 years they have to vote on it
again
again only giving the big middle finger
to veterans
well pat toomey can stick that middle
finger right up his [ __ ] ass
as far as i'm concerned
and republicans as well
and it seems as if that these
republicans are going to pass this pact
act this week
and the only reason why they're doing
all this nonsense is so they can change
the bill and they can say see we changed
it back see
democrats changed it and we want it
changed back and then we changed it back
blah blah blah blah blah that's what
they're gonna say
mark my words they passed this
[ __ ] this week
on sunday shows they'll be accusing
democrats of changing the bill back they
changed it back see we told you they
changed it
so i think the democrats and schumer and
the rest of them should tell the
republicans to [ __ ] off we're not
changing a goddamn word in this bill and
keep voting on the son of a [ __ ]
schumer has not announced the floor vote
i don't think as of yet
but he should announce today a floor
vote
and really honestly if they don't
[ __ ] vote for the son of a [ __ ] he
should bring the son of a [ __ ] to the
floor and let them vote against this
bastard over and over and over and over
again without changing a goddamn word
not a word not even a [ __ ] period
[ __ ] them
pat toomey can take his amendment and
stick it in his ass as far as i'm
concerned not only
is it is it un-american
and unpatriotic to vote against this
bill
because these veterans need this care
for the [ __ ] service that they did
for our country
they're sick these people are riddled
with cancer
they're going to die from this
from their service they're going to die
from their service to our country you
got it
and they don't give a [ __ ] they don't
give a [ __ ] they never have gave a [ __ ]
to be quite honest with you they don't
even give a [ __ ] when these people are
serving they don't give a [ __ ] the the
former guy the cheeto dust mobster mr
saudi
call them suckers and losers that's what
they believe
believe them when they're telling you
this stuff
when pat toomey is trying to make sure
that these veterans only get crumbs
it's because
it's because what john stewart said
it's not for the war machine so we don't
want it we don't want to spend the money
unless it's on the war machine
veterans don't put money in politicians
pockets
you think there's veterans groups
dumping millions of dollars into
politicians pockets in washington no
no
it's the [ __ ] it's the [ __ ] war
machine that dumps millions of dollars
into the pockets
of [ __ ] politicians in washington why
do you think they didn't want to undo
the war in afghanistan
you think that was just because they
like that war
because they thought it was
strategically great for america no it's
because
it's because the war machine kept
dumping money in their pockets to keep
that [ __ ] thing going
it's what it is
and now there's veterans paying the
ultimate price human beings our [ __ ]
citizens for crying out loud
paying the ultimate price
because they were given orders when
serving our country
and they did their duty
unlike some of these [ __ ] republicans
but it will continue on if you keep
voting for these pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
and it it it's very clear to see who
they are now like there's there's not
it's not hard to see
who the anti-democracy anti-veteran and
anti-anything really they're
anti-anything
anti-health care anti-woman
anti-equality anti-equity
anti-lgbt anything that you can name
their anti that
if it doesn't fit in their little white
male box
it's bad
it's really [ __ ] bad if it doesn't
really if it doesn't help them out their
white male ass
and it's time that us pro-democracy
people figure this out and stand
together against these [ __ ] fascists
stop worrying about other [ __ ]
democrats right i get it i get out right
i get it i get it this democrat that
democrat may not give you all the [ __ ]
that you want right now in the moment
and they may not do exactly what you
want which is not how government works
in the first place right i get it i get
it
it's cool that you are delusional even
though you're on the left fine [ __ ] i
get it but at least you're somewhat
tethered to reality that you believe in
democracy still to some degree
maybe
but if you're attacking that there's two
parties there's only two [ __ ]
that's it that's all you got and i know
wow goddamn tony we need a third party
andrew yang yeah andrew yang can take
his third party and stick it in his ass
all the way up in there rotate the
[ __ ] if he wants
i don't know what andrew gang's into
i don't know him i would have him on the
show to tell him that much
folks it it's we we are now
the needle is moving
the country realizes that republicans
are not people that need to be in charge
of gas prices these are not people that
need to be in charge of the economy
they're trying to marry children they're
trying to take away contraception from
married people they're trying to make
sure that women can't get life saving
[ __ ] medical treatment
because ah the bible says something on a
page somewhere they're not really sure
what it means they don't even know what
the [ __ ] abortion is
they can't figure it out
and we're gonna put these people in
charge of the economy
that's who you want who can't figure out
what the [ __ ] an abortion is that's what
you're gonna [ __ ] you're gonna put
these stupid [ __ ]
in charge of the economy are you [ __ ]
kidding me
people that can't figure out that joe
biden fist bumping the soddy prince is
bad but donald trump
having the saudis host their [ __ ]
their [ __ ] blood on their hands golf
tournament at his [ __ ] and his
[ __ ] bedminster and teeing off it on
his ex-wife's grave which i'm gonna talk
about today by the way i'm not gonna
ignore this anymore this this ivana
trump grave thing holy [ __ ] i'm gonna
tell you about this thing today
i'm gonna tell you exactly what i see
i've thought about this for days i've
looked at the picture a million times
and i'm gonna tell you what the hell
that is
i'm gonna tell you what it is
everyone wants to talk about tax breaks
and tax cheat and all that [ __ ] of
course it is for a tax break and the
donald trump doesn't do anything that
doesn't benefit his pocket personally
it's always a grip but i'm going to tell
you i'm going to tell you what the image
is
for ivana trump's grave
because i can't stop thinking about it
i can't stop seeing that [ __ ] image
and i waited a while to comment on the
image itself
because i wanted to be sure
but i'm gonna tell you what i see in
that photo
today
jesus christ
but it's time for us to act now
tomorrow in missouri there's a primary
if you're in missouri and there's other
states that are going to have primaries
too go
exercise go right
go engage in your ballot
whatever that means to you
and don't stop there don't just select
the people you want in the primary
make phone calls make text messages
you want to change the senate makeup
you want to pass
that assault weapons ban in the senate
well you're going to need to [ __ ]
work hard
if you want to pass that
that assault weapons ban in the senate
you can't just blame
democrats
for getting it passed which i don't
understand there's there's people out
there blaming democrats for getting the
assault weapons ban passed
i don't understand it i mean there's a
couple democrats that voted against it
but there's a couple republicans that
voted for it
i don't understand what the [ __ ] you're
talking about democrats got it passed
republicans didn't do a goddamn thing
but vote against it
so if you want that [ __ ] in the
senate you're gonna have to change the
senate folks you are gonna have to
change the senate you
they're not gonna change it
it's up to us we are the people we are
the [ __ ] government we are the
democracy
okay
it's us
not not anyone else but us
2016 when donald trump was elected
president united states and we allowed
him to to to seat three supreme court
justices which took away women's rights
in this country that is the voter's
fault
the voters did that
rather you want to [ __ ] believe it or
not they [ __ ] did that well
hillary clinton run by three million
more yeah i get it right i got it yep
she got more votes
and because our system in our country
everyone has to engage no matter what
the fascists are here
they are going to take your [ __ ]
rights
they're going to do it they're proving
that they'll do it
hell they're clamoring to do it more
just vote just vote them in and they'll
take your rights
take them [ __ ] seriously
because it's not just this election is
the most important one
2020
was the most important election
2018 was the most important election
cycle
2016 was the most important election
cycle and you weren't [ __ ] paying
attention
so quit making excuses stop
stop making excuses stop pointing
fingers who does blame who's not to
blame blah blah blah blah blah we can
agree on one goddamn thing that there's
only one party in this country anymore
that is interested in democracy and the
other party is interested in tearing it
down and taking it away from us
so what are you going to do while you
still have the vote
you're just going to sit at home and say
ah [ __ ] it's over anyways
are you gonna fight
you're gonna go to the ballot you're
gonna engage in our democracy do the
thing that democracies do which is kill
fascism with the ballot
and i'm not just talking about your
ballot
i'm telling you engage with your family
your friends your colleagues
that lady at the grocery store
who helps you check out your groceries a
couple times a week
when you go in to pay for your gas the
clerk at the gas station these things
are important
and it's easy to strike up a
conversation i'm gonna give you i'm
gonna give you at least three or four
things today
to strike up a conversation did you see
this guy in west virginia who's talking
about
teenage girls being raped as romantic
i'm telling you did you see that did you
see that [ __ ] no it's on the internet
he's a [ __ ] republican they're crazy
they're batshit crazy
they want to take your contraception
don't you see where i'm going with this
this is how you do it
this is how they've always done it you
know who they [ __ ] are you've talked
to them all day there's some [ __ ]
idiot at your work who can't stop
talking about chewing on lies
can't stop talking about it blah blah
blah q anon q anon q anon trump trump
manga maga trump trump let's go brandon
i'm a nazi i'm a nazi i love being a
nazi
you know what i'm talking about
you have to engage in your democracy to
keep it
and not just press blame on the people
that you think are pro-democracy not
doing enough
because you're going to let the fascists
take over
and i am not going to put up with it
that's right i'm not going to put up
with it
i'm going to keep doing my part yelling
and screaming in this microphone two
hours every single weekday noon eastern
11 central nine pacific on youtube
twitter and twitch and simon casting
from the midas touch facebook page
to give you guys the strategic outrage
that you need for these snowflake trump
supporters
boy are they delusional i'm gonna show
you some video from the the saudi blood
on your hands
trump invitational whatever the [ __ ]
that thing is and we're gonna go over
the grave of ivana
trump
stick around we'll be right back right
after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50 a day
you can help us help those true
americans recover from biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those trump
supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for joining us thanks for sticking
around for the break
thanks for joining us here on this
monday as you do every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch and simulcasting from the
minus touch facebook page all the people
over on facebook and the tubes of you
thanks for joining us and there are the
handful of people that always go over to
twitch
i don't know if you like twitch go over
there and follow us on twitch
that's and that'll be cool you can go
watch it on twitch too
and i'll show you at the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends everyone knows
that we love the tweety tweets and
trendy trends and i have
have a lot of stuff to get to today
here's the thing
i thought i thought gabe sanchez was
gonna be joining us so maybe i can talk
him into making an appearance um it
appears though he's having a lot of
construction done at his house they're
actually trying to make him his own
underground bunker um so there's a lot
of noise and a lot of construction noise
as they're digging
to make him an underground
bunker
uh i think that's what's happening over
there he can't hear a goddamn thing he
can't hear anything so maybe i'll get
him to join just to prove that yes gabe
sanchez is alive he is well
he's just working on digging his own
bunker bunker and his house
and now that he's away from his secret
bunker maybe i'll get him to join just
just a bit just a bit
i don't know possibly
possibly
that poor gabe yeah poor gabe
poor gabe
he is alive and well i promise
i promise he is alive he is well
he's here
um the
today's thumbnail is proof uh there you
go you see the uh past the past packed
act now there's jon tester john tester
was a little pissed off
about this packed act apparently he
worked all weekend on the phones to try
to get this thing passed um john tester
is the democrat from montana
um
and you see in the background here all
the
veterans
trying to uh get the idea out that hey
we're not going anywhere we're not gonna
we're not gonna go home
until you pass this son of a [ __ ] and
republicans really
figured out that they probably [ __ ] up
here
i think i think they're getting getting
a sense that they [ __ ] up big time
and and the reason why is because this
doesn't look good here is uh republicans
kill veterans by midas touch uh they
keep proposing this this got 1.2 million
views let's watch this
republicans blocked a burn pit bill
which is meant to help veterans exposed
to toxins while serving our country the
most despicable part of this whole thing
is watching on the senate floor ted cruz
fist-bumping and then patting each other
on the back when they blocked this bill
celebrating their victory over veterans
with cancer way to go guys
[Music]
it's [ __ ] disgusting it's [ __ ]
disgusting they know what they're doing
they know why they're doing it john
cornyn even tweeted that he knows that
they're doing it
oh well we're just getting revenge we're
just getting revenge haha [ __ ] you we'll
pass it next week don't worry don't
worry we'll pass it next week we just
want to [ __ ] all over veterans in the
meantime
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
these are the p these are the people who
claim to love veterans more than anyone
and that democrats can't be patriotic
and they can't support the veterans
democrats hate veterans blah blah blah
blah all the time with this nonsense
all they do is politicize veterans
that's all they do that's it that's it
and we shouldn't politicize veterans we
should politicize that republicans
[ __ ] don't want anything to do with
veterans not a god damn i mean the only
thing they want is their [ __ ] vote
and for them to contribute to the maga
fund that's it they want their they want
their recurring contribution to the maga
fund
and they want their vote anything else
pass that i don't want to talk to you i
don't want to deal with you i don't want
to i hear anything when you're serviced
if you got sick if you need health care
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you don't want to
hear it that's how republicans feel
about veterans
they could give a [ __ ] less frankly as
if the
i think their thought is pat toomey and
the rest of them ted cruz and
john kennedy and josh hawley
fist pounding on the senate floor
on top of these veterans cancer ridden
bodies you [ __ ] i think they're like
well let them die then we won't have to
pay for health care [ __ ] them [ __ ] them
that's what that's how they treated
americans during the pandemic you
remember the lieutenant governor of
[ __ ] texas that piece of [ __ ] he's
like ah old people understand old people
understand you remember back in 2020
[ __ ] if i gave here i hadn't pulled the
tape
you remember the lieutenant governor of
texas saying [ __ ] old people they'll do
a service to the country and they'll die
that way we can get on with this stuff
they are willing to walk over dead
bodies to get what they want and what
they want is to keep their [ __ ] power
that's it
they don't give a [ __ ] about anything
else and that's why they voted against
the pack act after they voted for it
it's because joe manchin took away a
little bit of their power
by doing a deal with chuck schumer and
that pissed him off and that pissed him
off enough to [ __ ] on the bodies the
dead cancer-ridden bodies of veterans
after those veterans had honorably
served our country
that's what republicans do
and i'm gonna show you just how they do
it when we surf the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends today so let's not
waste much time and let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome one back to the tony
michaels podcast we have reached the
part of the show where we round up all
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
with the [ __ ] list roundup
oh boy do i have a lot of footage to
show you let's see if we can get to um
oh here you go here's more republican
yeah i just go down the [ __ ] list
here
just go down the [ __ ] list we're
gonna watch a lot of video today
we're probably gonna watch some of this
[ __ ] more than once
like this [ __ ] idiot this senator
carnes
in randolph county the 11th
in west virginia of course he's a
republican
he's saying vile [ __ ] into a microphone
on the legislator house floor
and he's trying to make a point of why
teenage girls who get pregnant because
of rape are the problem this is the
point he's trying to make here
they're the problem
they wear mini skirts they think it's
romantic blah blah blah this [ __ ]
idiot
watch what this democrat says to him how
in the [ __ ] does this guy know what he's
saying
how does he know does he have experience
corn senator carnes
you [ __ ] kid diddler listen to this
[ __ ]
um
you know the dynamic in these
relationships
quite often is that the child
has a very romanticized view of what's
happening they think this is their
boyfriend
would you agree with that
i don't know what you're talking about
sir you don't know what i'm talking
about thank you
so
senator baldwin here a democrat
of the 10th basically says i have no
idea what the [ __ ] you're talking about
do you i don't do you have experience in
this where you're trying to romanticize
teenage girls so you can rape them what
the [ __ ] is this guy talking about
listen again these republican kid
diddlers have been enough of these [ __ ]
um
you know the the dynamic in these
relationships
quite often is that the child
has a he's talking about a little girl
he's talking about a little girl
very romanticized view of what's
happening they think this is their
boyfriend
their boyfriend
so he's blaming
he's blaming a little teenage girl who
gets raped and pregnant
on her thoughts of romanticizing that
her rapist is her boyfriend
would you agree with that
i don't know what you're talking about
sir you don't know what i'm talking
about thank you
this is absolutely batshit crazy
why why why do we have to continue to
take these people seriously why do we
have to continue this
we shouldn't have to this is not a thing
we have to do
you can decide enough's enough of this
[ __ ]
this guy's name's robert kearns
bobby bobby the rapist
i don't know he says child rape victims
romanticize relationships with their
rapists that's what rex types in here
so west virginia are you are you going
are you gonna let this [ __ ]
romanticize this person who thinks that
rape
raping a child could be romanticized
what the [ __ ] how in the [ __ ] are they
sitting around thinking about this type
of [ __ ]
you know they're always complaining
about gas prices but the only time they
get in front of a microphone on a house
floor is to talk about diddling your
kids
[ __ ] speaking of kid diddlers
look at this group of [ __ ] morons
at the saudi blood on your hands trump
invitational
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] by the way
apparently marjorie taylor green showed
up twice at this [ __ ] thing
acting like she's gonna run for vice
president or some [ __ ] look at this fat
[ __ ] number one look at this fat
[ __ ]
someone's gonna convince me that this
guy weighs 180 pounds give me a [ __ ]
break
180 my ass
the [ __ ] out of here with this fat ass
[ __ ]
somehow he's healthier than joe biden
what the [ __ ] this guy this guy couldn't
even hold up a goddamn bicycle
let alone ride one and have the ability
to get his toe caught on the toe cage
and fall off of it you fat [ __ ]
let's listen to the crowd
[Applause]
you notice something you notice
something about this crown you notice
something seems like a bunch of [ __ ]
white dudes
they're [ __ ] nazis
someone uh the patriot takes post this
and said four more years this is a
low-key trump rally
well the only reason why it seems like a
low-key trump rally is because the only
the only the only people that would show
up to this [ __ ] thing are a bunch of
goddamn traitors
who the [ __ ] would show up to this saudi
blood on your hands [ __ ]
trump invitational number one he's
hosting it and the saudis are paying him
to host it who the [ __ ] would show up to
this thing besides a bunch of goddamn
manga traders
well
i will show you a couple people that
aren't maga traders that showed up to
this thing
oh it's hilarious you you saw
the news a headline that someone was
uh
trolling field phil nicholson when he
was teeing off at one point well we
found out who it was which is even
better now that we found out who it was
speaking of the trump invitational buck
sexton and his [ __ ] his sidekick
showed up at the tr the
the trump saudi uh
uh
lovin lovin is it lovin tournament the
love trump saudi love tournament i think
is what it's called
um
and they did their little
podcast and they recorded trump talking
about how he's butt hurt that putin made
him run for president
and didn't allow him to become stay at
the american money launderer i'm not
[ __ ] you i mean he didn't say as
much but that's what he's trying to say
here listen to this [ __ ] i could have
done so many things i could if i wanted
to i purposely we didn't do business i
could have grabbed so many by the [ __ ]
oh it would have been great it would
have been great but as the president you
can't really do that because they're
constantly watching you they constantly
have a microphone you're they're
constantly taking notes it's so it's so
hard to commit a coup when they're
trying to record you commit a coup i
kicked the [ __ ] camera person out i
made them burn all the notes i ate i ate
the [ __ ] white house log do you know
how hard it is
to commit a coup and to be treasonous
when you're the president of the united
states it's difficult i could have known
so many things if i'd just been dictator
get the [ __ ] out of here
sort of funny if somebody came in from
some foreign country and stayed at the
hotel in washington right yeah and
they'd stay there and they'd pay you
five six hundred bucks for a night
there'd be a headline trump accepts
saudi money and i i believe so there
there trump is um
showing you how much showing you how
much he can relate to common people
common people out there
that he thinks five six hundred bucks is
nothing right there right there in the
tape he's telling you [ __ ]
fi if 500 600 bucks means anything then
you're you're [ __ ] worthless
it's literally what he's saying when
he's saying that is oh
they're coming and paying five hundred
dollars for a room that's nothing i took
all kinds of saudi money i took all
kinds of foreign money forget five or
six hundred bucks if someone thinks five
or six hundred bucks is a lot of money
they're [ __ ] they're poor
they're worthless that's what he's
saying
believe you know i've lost at least a
billion and i expect it to i it's
nothing but i'll be expected to lose a
billion once he won he expected that he
expected it
he was disappointed that he won because
now he's gonna lose
a billion don't get the [ __ ] out of here
with a billion dollars and [ __ ]
bet you i lost a billion two billion
dollars certainly in terms of money that
i could have made if you just run
regular business and never got it if i
didn't if i
just didn't do it
if i would not have obeyed my bladdy
daddy and not been coerced to run by
putin so that i could get a hotel in
moscow
and a tower in moscow i would not have
won and i would have been able to
launder all kinds of money
so disappointing that i wasn't able to
launder all that money because vladimir
putin forced me to become president
so that he
so he had one of his russian agents as
president i bet it would have been
anywhere from a billion to two billion
in fact forbes said that i'm the only
president and and i consider this a
great compliment because it said i was
honest because i could have made a
fortune as president i could have made
i'm better than all of these people that
are making their money and i could have
made a fortune but okay i can't i can't
take it anymore i can't take it anymore
and that's enough that's enough the
point is
the point is is that he's really [ __ ]
butthurt that putin made him run for
president instead of keeping him as the
head american money launderer he's
really pissed off about this
he's upset about this
that's why the ukraine thing really gets
in his crawl
because i think trump really feels like
if putin would have just would have just
not worked so hard to make him president
he could have he could have ran for
president caused all the chaos hillary
clinton could have won and they could
open up a media machine and grifted and
laundered so much money he's pissed off
about it
that putin did he's mad that putin did
this to him that forced him to run to
get that [ __ ] tower
speaking of politicians and running and
pieces of [ __ ] look at these two [ __ ]
chuckleheads
look at these two [ __ ]
chuck todd and joe manchin why in the
[ __ ] why in the [ __ ] does anyone watch
this [ __ ]
like actually give it its ratings nbc
news this [ __ ] meet the press it used
to be an actual
an actual show that you could go to
to get some [ __ ] news but then you
have this these two [ __ ] idiots
chuck todd give me a [ __ ] break when
are they gonna fire this guy
chuck come come be come be uh uh an
intern on our show i'll give you a job
of being an intern
you don't need to be a host of meet the
press the [ __ ] let's listen do you hope
democrats keep control of the house and
senate
i think people are sick and tired of
politics chuck i really do i think
they're sick and tired of dem no we're
not we're not sick and tired of politics
this is the nonsense this is the
[ __ ] we are not sick and tired of
politics this is exactly what we want
this should be exactly what you want you
shouldn't want the politics folks you
should want to politicize everything
that's why they always [ __ ] win
that's why joe manchin joe manchin's
saying this for his goddamn republican
voters because you got to remember
joe manchin is not trying to [ __ ]
appease pro-democracy democratic voters
he's not whenever he's talking whenever
he says something whenever he makes a
vote in public
when he's not doing deals behind closed
doors he is talking to republican voters
got it
that's who vote for him his republican
motors
he's got to convince him that yeah it
says democrat behind my name but i'm
actually a republican
and chuck todd does a great job at
helping him here
not calling him out on it immediately
like this long pause watch this long
pause tired of politics
i think it's a really long pause chuck
todd should have jumped in and said uh
that's a really long pause a city yes or
a no
you you you [ __ ]
see so you're a republican or a democrat
listen to this nonsense for sick and
tired of politics chuck i really do i
think they're sick and tired of
democrats and republicans fighting and
feuding and holding pieces of
legislation hostage because they didn't
get what they wanted or something or
someone might get credit for something
why don't we start doing something for
our country why don't we just say this
is good for america yeah then kill the
filibuster [ __ ] you want to do
something good for your country joe
manchin kill the filibuster
listen i'm going to turn this guy off
here
because i i can't take i can't take
joe manchin anymore but listen if you
want to make joe manchin irrelevant
again
make mansion irrelevant again
then all you have to do is you have to
go and engage in these senate races
because here's the facts joe manchin is
not up for a re-election
he's not and when he is up for
re-election he will be courting
republican voters because there's not
enough democratic voters in west
virginia to get him elected at this
point
maybe we can get enough pro-democracy
voters to maybe primary him one day but
it doesn't exist right now it doesn't
exist
right now in the moment
and besides he's not up for re-election
so if you want to if you want to be
pissed off at this guy
if you want to be pissed off at this guy
be pissed off at him but take your anger
out
by helping tim ryan's campaign helping
fetterman's campaign warnock kelly
hell whoever wins here in missouri
tomorrow whoever that democrat and
primary is can probably beat eric
schmidt or eric greitens
they can win i'm telling you they can
[ __ ] win because people are not tired
of politics joe manchin people are tired
of trumpism
they're tired of trumpism they're tired
of lies
that's what they're [ __ ] sick of
they're not sick of politics we're ready
to politic we're ready to do it
some of us anyways hal spark points out
here
nina turner and i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna
start doing this i'm [ __ ] sick of
this [ __ ]
were these these
nina turner is not pro-democracy folks i
don't give a [ __ ] what you say you can
love her you can whatever she's not
pro-democracy
this is not a pro-democracy message this
is anti-democracy this is autocracy
this is dictorial ship that they want
nina turner says friendly reminder that
potus can cancel every dime a student
debt with a signature it's really that
simple and how sparks points out no he
cannot this is a [ __ ] lie
stop lying to people stop lying to
people that you want an authoritarian
state why do you want to give away all
your power to one person
if you do that in ron desantis or donald
trump or someone else wins again and you
give away all the power to one person we
may be [ __ ] nina turner
we need to stop this we really need to
give control back to congress and the
only way to do it is stop lying to
people stop [ __ ] lying it's nonsense
this is [ __ ] you can't
the way you change the policy is to vote
people in who are really serious about
policy and i don't just mean that agree
with you on every single policy point
someone who is actually serious
that is really serious about not nina
turner nina turner is not serious about
policy she's not serious about it she's
not
she nina turner is not serious about
policy
if we elect people who are actually
serious about policy who are willing to
consider the policy in front of them who
are willing to do the work that it takes
to do government to compromise sometimes
and not do this all well if we don't get
this then we want nothing
well a hundred percent of nothing
is nothing
that's what it is that's not democracy
that's autocracy you either you either
do it my way or you're out of here and
we don't get anything that's autocracy
folks that's not democracy that's not we
the people that's not progressing that's
not getting closer to equity inequality
it's not
it's going back
it's more of this [ __ ] nonsense from
these people like this [ __ ] idiot
let's see where who is this guy he's i
don't know he's i think this is westward
yeah this is west virginia again it's
not the same white guy it's a different
white guy from west virginia but it
might as well be the same white guy
now this guy's not making arguments that
that a a rapist of a of a teenage girl
is romantic he's not making that
argument he's making just as bad of an
argument though let's listen who
doesn't want to really be involved in
the life at all really
he knows that if if she carries through
the pregnancy he's going to have
possibly some sort of child support
obligation
and so what he wants to do is he wants
to
in a sense encourage her to go and
find a way to get an abortion because it
feels like this guy has experience in
this not just not just once but more
than once
this guy this guy has gotten more than
one woman pregnant
and he was terrified of the child
support he was terrified that he'd have
to financially you know make make mends
of the mistakes that he made
that he would have to have a part in a
life
this pro-lifer he would actually have a
have to have a part in the life
and he had to do the thing that he
didn't want to do which was force and
pay for a woman to get an abortion
that's what i'm seeing here
i don't know about you that's what i'm
seeing here
that's what this guy's telling me he is
projection folks it's projection
what else am i supposed to think
every single time that they say
something and ends up that's what the
[ __ ] they're doing
they're their their [ __ ] nonsense
explanations of the policies that they
want to have their fascist policies that
they want to have is always projection
so this guy's saying
that he knows that the reason why men
encourage women to get abortions is
because they don't want to pay child
support it feels like to me
this guy this guy's giving me little
dick energy and he's giving me the
energy a projection here but let's
continue what he says because he knows
that if if it's a certain individual if
he has any kind of familiarity with her
uh he knows that she might be of such a
state of mind she may be in such a
vulnerable position
he's saying he's saying it's the woman's
fault you got it did you catch it they
always do this it's always their fault
it's their fault
it's their fault and i should get to the
side it's not your body or chores it's
my white man
choice your body but i mean it's my
choice that's what he's saying
that she decides it's not worth
everything he's going to put me through
to carry this this uh pregnancy forward
there's more projection there's more
projection from the west virginia white
dude the kid diddler here
hey i'm gonna put you through a lot of
hell if you have this baby i'm gonna put
you through some [ __ ] hell boy i'm
gonna put you through some hell if you
don't go have an abortion that's what it
sounds like this guy has told a woman
before in his life i i that's what it
sounds like to me
i mean i don't know what it sounds like
to you but it sounds like this [ __ ]
idiot here has done that before
how else would he know this
how else would he know this that this is
the facts that this this is the rule not
the exception
it's going to be easier it's going to be
better for me to go and just terminate
this life
and so what she does is she goes over to
virginia she goes over to some other
state where
abortion is legal and she goes and gets
the abortion
and so
what the [ __ ] does that got to do with
you
what the [ __ ] does that got to do with
you not a goddamn thing but he doesn't
care and the reason why he doesn't care
is cause listen why he doesn't why he
gives a [ __ ] so much
about the relationship that this woman
may have with this man or this man may
have with this woman i think that's a
really uh clear possibility if if we
enact the second amendment here
uh i don't want to be doing anything
whatsoever that is encouraging
folks to go and get an abortion
so what this [ __ ] idiot this
amendment is doing is it it gets rid of
child support
so here's here's what happens here's
what happens here's what this guy is
doing he clearly has been in a position
before where he's had a woman who was
pregnant and he needed her to get an
abortion so he didn't have to pay child
support because he definitely wasn't
going to stay with this woman
because you know he's he's a manly man
he's macho he's makismo he's a real man
so he needed this woman to get an
abortion so we didn't have to pay child
support because he knew it was his but
he needed her to get an abortion so
and he that's just against his [ __ ]
morals so here's what he thinks
look here's here's how we can have it
both ways we don't have to make sure to
saddle men
with these babies we just saddle the
women with these babies i mean we'll
force the women to have babies and then
remove any responsibility
whatsoever for the men that are going to
vote us out because we're creating a
situation because this is what's
happening this is what this is the
problem that he sees
with the
what row has created
this is the dog catching the car
and he's telling you out loud from his
experiences in his life
and what his constituents are telling
him his donors are telling him they're
like look man this row thing's really
bad the reason why we never thought
about this we never really thought this
through we just said pro-life pro-life
democrats want to kill babies so we
could win elections but this overturning
row thing it's really biting us in the
ass because here's the thing
if we're going to force women to have
babies and we're going to force men
to pay child support well [ __ ] they're
going to vote against us the men not the
will i mean [ __ ] the women
[ __ ] them we don't need their vote we're
gonna get rid of their vote anyways our
goal is to get rid of their votes so we
won't have to worry about that but the
men if we saddle them with the child
support
because you know that's what every
[ __ ] [ __ ] republican is thinking
out there you know that's what they're
thinking i mean i said when it first
happened that when when a trumped-up
white dude walks into a gas station at
some red state somewhere and asked
where's the condoms where the [ __ ] are
the condoms to the clerk and the clerk
says we don't have condoms condoms are
banned you can't buy condoms in this
state and they go why not we'll be
because republicans banned all
contraception
that was going to be the realization but
here it's a step further because of
their projection
they've thought this through because of
a situation they've been in
where they where they didn't want to pay
child support so they were encouraging
a
woman to not make her choice but to make
his choice it was his choice not to pay
child support so
their thought is if we can just decouple
child support if we just do away with
child support men paying child support
by the way i'm sure this [ __ ] guy is
100 okay with a woman paying child
support he's not okay with a man
because what the hell would be the
difference
if a woman wanted to pay child support
she'd have that baby the man would have
the baby and she'd have to pay god damn
it
that just makes sense the woman is the
one that is responsible for these these
these lives
that i as a pro-lifer want them to have
to force them to carry the term
rather they're incest rape
or otherwise
especially if it's a romantic type of
rape you know the kind where an older
man
with the teenage get the [ __ ] out of
here this west virginia [ __ ]
but here's the thing this guy
this politician is standing on the floor
telling his constituents
who are terrified
that they're gonna have to keep paying
child support because republicans are
forcing women to have babies
they're like whoa wait a second this
abortion thing wasn't that bad
it stopped me from having to pay child
support
that's who he's talking to
that's who he's talking to the
trumped-up white dudes that are really
pissed off when they go into the gas
station and realize condoms have been
banned that's who he's talking to
because he's one of them that's why he's
[ __ ] one of them jesus [ __ ] christ
it's just it doesn't end
it doesn't in there the stupidity
doesn't in there with children their
focus oh man they're obsessed here's
sebastian gorka
and sam sarbo
[ __ ] kevin sarbo's wife
absolutely obsessed with indoctrinating
children they're obsessed with it they
can't stop thinking about how they're
going to indoctrinate children so it's
all projection the entire thing
listen to this dumb stupid [ __ ] that
they say that they're talking about here
this really is [ __ ] that these people
think they're intelligent
they think they're smart they think
they're great they think they're
thinkers
and so they're going to solve the world
with these problems like kids raising
their hands to ask a question
why the rebranding so the first thing
that you learn in school is you have to
raise your hand to ask a question that's
a deterrent that a deterrent
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
there's what she's saying in this in
this one sentence
is that a child raising their hand to
ask a question is a deterrent
the child wants to ask a question the
proper way in a conversation to ask a
question is to signal that you want to
say something not just to talk over
everybody
these people have absolutely no decency
and no empathy and the reason why is
they can't even see that raising the
hand isn't that isn't just a [ __ ]
classroom thing
that's a hey we're having discussion
with a lot of people here it's a
courtesy to raise your hand to signal
it's a signal
right i mean we haven't always walked
around with [ __ ] buzzers
and lights like that's just the signal
that you give when you have something to
say
you raise a finger you raise your hand
what the [ __ ] is she talking about she's
saying that this is indoctrination and
it's a deterrent for someone to say
something the signal
the signal that you give when you want
to ask a question or say something is a
deterrent what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
as if as if a stop sign is a deterrent
from people stopping in an intersection
what the [ __ ] are these people yammering
about
listen to the stupidity it gets worse
that's actually teaching you viscerally
because you you embody it
don't ask
that actually no it is to ask you
[ __ ] idiot
how how in the [ __ ] do these people
listen to this garbage and think yeah
these people are really smart oh my god
she's intelligent holy [ __ ] the signal
to make sure that you have your voice
heard that's a deterrent from having
your but what are you talking about like
that's the actual thing that's that's
the cultural thing that gives you your
ability to speak
to be heard
it's not a deterrent you dumb
[ __ ]
eventually becomes trust the expert
that's not education
here it comes back here it comes back to
we're so goddamn dumb
that people who actually use their
[ __ ] noggins and their brains
who who end up living in a [ __ ] in a
[ __ ] space that is liberal democracy
and liking liberal democracy not big l
small l are liberals and they're
libtards and they don't know what
they're talking about what are you what
are you talking about so you're saying
when a teacher is in a classroom
and she's giving a lesson on math and
she asks a question
and there's six students that know the
answer
what are they supposed to do what are
they are they supposed to give the
hitler sign the hail hitler sign what
are they supposed to do besides raise
their hand to signal that they know the
answer to the question
a deterrent this is really stupid [ __ ]
that's not a thinking person that's a
non-thinking person that's what the
schools are turning out
the person raising their hand is
actually the person who has something to
say who has thought about what you are
saying or thought about what you have
asked and have the answer to the
question that you have sarbo sam sarbo
you dumb [ __ ] here's the other
thing kevin sarbo is wacky he's a
wackadoo he's a looney tune
something tells me something tells me
that maybe these two
sit around the tables searching the q
and on internet
with each other because this is batshit
crazy listen to this again
and and and and your say tony why is
this significant
this is the [ __ ] that your family's
listening to
this is the [ __ ] that your family who is
who is steeped in manga delusion is
listening to and and i'm not saying to
listen to this specific program
but they're spreading the [ __ ] all over
the place
to say certain things that you do
for courtesy
for decency
for respect
are are are designed to dilute you
and designed to take away your your
your individualism what the [ __ ] are you
talking about listen
that's what school produces why the
rebranding so the first thing that you
learned in school is you i want to go
back to that first sentence that he says
why rebranding why are we always
rebranding because they always are
rebranding folks they're always
retelling the story they're always
whitewashing [ __ ]
to whitewash the fact that raising your
hand to ask that question is somehow
[ __ ]
brainwashing is absolutely ridiculous
why the rebranding so the first thing
that you learned in school is you have
to raise your hand to ask a question
that's a deterrent that's actually
teaching you viscerally because you you
embody it
don't ask that actually eventually
becomes trust the expert it's actually i
i can't i can't take it anymore i can't
take it anymore and i said these people
believing they are intelligent is
getting really stupid
this is getting really stupid
that that they think that this is
intelligent stuff
and it leads to it leads to the [ __ ]
that we have
on the floor of the senate and the floor
of the house is because people like this
dumb [ __ ] are the tail that is wagging
the dog
there is there are what making our
legislators so [ __ ] stupid
and saying and doing stupid [ __ ] like
voting against the pack act
let's listen to jon stewart on abc on
sunday here's more jon stewart about
what is real and what's not or in dire
need
look senate republicans voted for this
just a month ago now voted against it uh
put that aside for a second let's look
at the reason they're saying now they
say uh that they they want this spending
to be discretionary spending not
mandatory
spending that's washington speak for
saying that it has to be voted on every
year they want to vote on that amendment
are you okay with them getting a vote on
that amendment would you still favor
this bill even even if that amendment
passed
sure vote on the absolutely
i absolutely vote on the amendment bring
the amendment to the floor uh give it
the same threshold that the veterans had
to clear which is the senate threshold
of 60 because it's senate math not real
life math give them the threshold give
them the amendment by the way john
the chimney amendment doesn't change it
from mandatory to discretionary it's
still mandatory the toomey amendment is
really about capping the fund it's about
putting caps on it and giving it a
sunset clause for 10 years
now we've been through this with the 911
first responders what toomey's amendment
wants to do is make sure that our sick
and dying veterans
have the pleasure
that our 9 11 first responders at ground
zero bad of having to come back to
washington hadn't hand riddled with
cancer and marched through the halls of
the hill begging for money
and that's a great point is that exactly
that's exactly what they want these
republicans want these veterans to come
back every single year to big
to big for this money
they want them to come in big so they
can take pictures with them and talk to
them and act like they give a [ __ ] about
them
every 10 years republicans get to have
this this little this little [ __ ] show
that they love to have so they can talk
about how democrats don't like veterans
even though they're voting against them
even though they're voting against them
okay here we go i'm gonna
this is the picture
that you all been waiting for this is
the uh the photo
of the tr the the ivana trump grave
at betminster
and i'm going to explain this i'm going
to explain this picture i'm going to
explain it as soon as we come back from
this break stick around don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part and blanket
specifically works to make you feel safe
and cozy after your involvement on
january 6th and if you're one of the
other members of congress who also
helped with the attempted coup pardon
blanket will protect you too pardon
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and they're
a hundred percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your part in blanket
today for just 99.99
actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome and welcome welcome back to the
show
i told you we would go
and i would talk about the ivana trump
gravesite
i avoided this tweeting about it for a
while
several different reasons
but i thought about it
i thought about it um for for for
several days
before i tweeted now i tweeted about the
grave and about him trying to get the
tax good but but the picture of it the p
here here it is let's make it a little
bigger let's take that off let's make
this a little bigger how we'll make it
the whole screen there you go you see
the whole screen here is the is the
is the ivana trump grave at betminster
now apparently this is just off the
fairway of the first hole
you know gay and betminster now i i
actually meant to go look at a map to
see if we could i could figure out
exactly where this [ __ ] thing is
but a lot of people pointing out there's
like a like a fence in the background
some people thought it was a barbed wire
fence
and it appears to be a barbed wire fence
now have you ever grew up in a rural
area or
you know drove along a highway where
there's like cattle fields or livestock
fields a lot of times there's these
barbed wire fences along the highway
when when they get along the highway
here
yeah you know it kind of looks like a
bob or fence but this is not a barbed
wire fence that's not what this is
because i thought that too at first
right
this is the marking of the gravesite
they they use string to mark it off here
right
but it looks like a barbed wire fence
like it would be a boundary but this is
a boundary
this is a boundary here and let me
explain why this is a boundary there is
a berm on the other side of this ditch
this is a [ __ ] ditch
i'm not kidding you that's what this is
this is a [ __ ] ditch
he buried ivana trump that's all i could
keep thinking when i watched when i
looked at this picture
i couldn't think anything else i looked
at it over and over and now there were
some other photoshop versions of this
and the reason why the other ones are
photoshopped is because when you look at
it
the the flowers and and the headstone
are turned the other direction
it's photoshopped that one's not real
this one's the real one this is the real
one where it's got it corded off the
other reason why you know
um this is the this is the site
is because of the markings on the on the
grass
the markings on the grass here they
prepared this site
and there's dead spots in this grass
and the reason why there's dead spots in
this grass is because they'd have to put
up a tent they'd have to put up the
equipment to lower the casket down into
the grave
there's a lot of stuff that goes into
and equipment that goes into
bearing an empty casket i mean the
casket i don't know some people are
saying it's empty some people are saying
he they cremated her but
they buried a gold casket here i don't
know if her ashes are in here
they're in donald trump junior's crack
pipe i'm not sure
i don't know i don't know the facts on
that where her body was or wasn't
but if you also look there's this little
patch of grass here
well that's from that's from probably
the front row of chairs
that were set up
but if that's the case that's only one
set of chairs
does that mean only one you know maybe i
don't know there's maybe eight ten
chairs that could fit there
does that mean only eight or ten people
watch this casket go down into the
ground
i don't know
beats me now some people are criticizing
the headstone
now the headstone just has her name her
date of birth
and the day she died on
now this is very common and what i mean
by very common is there's normally a
temporary marker put on a grave
now in a lot of cases it's just like a
little
metal
stake
that has the name
the date that they died that passed and
the date or date they were born the date
they passed sometimes just a year
but there's a marker it's a temporary
marker until a permanent marker a
tombstone as we know it would come and
mark the grave
but a lot of people were criticizing the
gravestone that i did looks like they
just threw down this
[ __ ] piece of marble with her name
her birth date and her death date right
there on the grave and then
and then toss this
bouquet of flowers that they picked off
the buffet inside the betminster on top
of the grave
which i'm not saying that doesn't look
like it you would think for the money
that this [ __ ] claims to have he
would not have buried her in a [ __ ]
ditch
he probably would afford
afford a little better bouquet of
flowers and more flowers for this grave
more than likely
but folks this is a [ __ ] ditch
that's what this is
when they did the dirt work for wherever
this is at
they made sure that the water would
divert around the fairway
okay they got to make sure that water
diverts around certain parts of the golf
course they can't have water destroying
the golf course so when they built this
golf course originally whoever designed
it
would have designed for ditches around
the fairways to make sure water could
drain away from the fairways and get out
of the fairways to not cause damage
to the fairway and that's what this is
there's a berm on the other side they
did dirt work that's the reason why the
grass is tall and it drops you can see
that this drops look at the trees
the trees are down in the ditch
he buried a
trump his first wife in a [ __ ] ditch
now a lot of people are saying that he
gets tax breaks and that may be the
truth i don't know
i don't know if he gets tax breaks or
not i'm not really sure
i mean that people have posted the law
here i'll show it to you
here we'll show it to you i'll show you
the little a little thing from the uh
the website of uh new jersey
[Music]
here it is
cemeteries funerals and jersey in jersey
texas
here this thing is
um and it's from the state of new jersey
and of course the uh
parts highlighted are what are exempt
from cemeteries
and it says quote cemetery company means
an individual corporation partnership
association and other public or private
entity which owns
operates controls and manages land
or places used or dedicated for the use
of burial of human remains
so that's how they define as a cemetery
company right
okay well that that sounds
that sounds appropriate now there's some
other stipulations of what you are
prohibited do by a cemetery company like
you can't manufacture or sell vaults
private mausoleums uh monuments markers
bronze memorials and conduct any funeral
home or or business a profession of
uh mortuary science
so you can't own a funeral you can't you
can't have can't have your cake and eat
it too okay
in other words cemetery companies
can't be you know can't be selling this
stuff to their customers
lifelong customers or
you know either way you want to look at
it death long customers
now here is what everyone is pointing
out the exemptions the tax exemptions
that they believe that donald trump is
trying to get it says the act relieves
cemetery companies of
from payment of
real property taxes on lands dedicated
to cemetery purposes income tax
sales and use tax which
really the two things that are most
important here
uh because donald trump
he's definitely a tax cheat
you know what i mean like like he's not
telling the truth on his taxes no
[ __ ] way that this does this guy tell
the truth on his returns i don't believe
that do you believe that
i mean i think that's why he won't show
us his returns is because he lies on him
he lies on him that's why he didn't want
to show them to us
but the two things that are actual um
big big tax breaks here the property tax
and the sales and use tax
the sales and use tax is a big one
because bedminster is not only a golf
course but it's got restaurants it's got
dining halls
it's got
big rooms where they sell catering they
have hotels which is all sales and use
tax
now
i actually doubt
that the state of new jersey
would register
donald trump's bet minister as a
cemetery company because if you read
this part up here it says registration
so you it does you just don't bury a
[ __ ] body on your property and then
you're a cemetery that's not what
happens
that's not what happens you have to
actually register now
i'm not saying that he's not doing this
because i'm sure donald trump has had a
had an idea here that hey
i know a good way to get a tax break and
he'll probably have all kinds of
lawsuits and he'll do all kinds of
stupid [ __ ] to try to get new jersey to
make betminster a cemetery
but i'm sure bet the state of new jersey
will tell donald trump to go [ __ ]
himself
about this [ __ ] grave that he's made
there at bedminster to try to make it a
cemetery company
because you can't register it the state
of new jersey the law requires all
businesses to register with the state
for tax purposes
at least 15 days before starting
business
got it
so read there 15 days before starting
business now what i'm saying is donald
trump has probably heard before then in
the state of new jersey if you bury a
body on a piece of property you can get
taxes exempt forever that's what he
heard he believed it and he's like okay
we'll bury her in that ditch over there
[ __ ] it well just uh you know just pick
pick the nicest ditch
pick the nicest one the greatest one
the smooth spectacular ditch
and put her in that ditch
what he didn't understand is there's
actual things steps you have to go
through to do these things
and that's probably where he's gonna
fall short
on
getting out of taxes
but he'll try i don't doubt it i think
he'll try i think i'll try here
seeing what the new jersey state law is
but i wonder if what you need to do is
and you can file online here apparently
um and you can go online you can file
the division of revenue and enterprise
services
for this tax exemption
because that's what you're filing for to
be a cemetery company to receive these
exemptions
in the uh new jersey cemetery act of
2003
so
i guess i guess a person needs to go and
find out when he hired the person to
kick her down the stairs excuse me the
day she fell down the stairs wink um
and when he applied
for this registration for this tax
exemption to the new york cemetery act
that's probably
what an investigator would do
just saying
so
so donald trump buries his ex-wife
ivana trump in a [ __ ] ditch that's
all i could think like the tax exemption
thing sure yeah i get it that that
donald trump would want
you know he would want
the tax exemption he would try or
whatever
but he buried her in a [ __ ] ditch and
here's here's that good shot of the uh
the headstone again her name
the date she was more than the date she
died and it really does look like they
just tossed
this bouquet of flowers that was i don't
know on the front desk or something like
that they're like ah there's some
flowers out there
someone probably probably felt sorry for
the grave
and then it does look like they just
threw this stone down they didn't place
it decent or anything you just threw it
in the dirt
but again
i want to reassure everybody i'm sure
i'm sure donald trump will buy some
cheap ass headstone some gaudy ass
classless headstone
for ravana
but this is just the temporary marker
maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm wrong i mean i
you know i've been wrong before not many
times
but i've been wrong before so
ivana trump
got put in a [ __ ] ditch got put in
the ditch speaking of bedminster
um
we we heard uh the other day
that
a golfer was uh uh heckled
here's the video
of uh
if i get it here uh here's the phil
mickelson
here it is at the at the saudi blood
tournament
the saudi blood tournament that he
played in
here's him gonna tee off listen to the
crowd
he goes to swing
phil mickelson phil nicholson lining up
oh there's hecklers
hecklers really got to phil mickelson
here
oh at the saudi blood tournament
so there's there's the uh
i tried to do golf commentary i [ __ ]
hate golf i'm not much of a golfer
i mean i'll drive the car around and
drink beer but hey i just stand just
swinging the clubs and [ __ ] yeah it's
just not my thing but here's the thing
everyone was like oh yeah that's great i
wonder who did that
hmm
who was it who was it
who
was it
well now i know it was the good liars
and they were there at the uh the live
tournament i think i've got another
picture of them with their quiet plea
signs
uh but the good liars say we gave phil
mickelson some words of encouragement
during his backswing
at trump's golf course yesterday at the
blood the blood doer the blood soddy to
her
let's look at this perspective when phil
mickelson is trying to tee off all right
behind me right there is phil mickelson
the face of this new golf league being
bankrolled by the saudi government 100
million dollars that's all it took for
him to come here holy [ __ ] 100 million
bucks that's it that's that's all the
blood money that it takes to get someone
at a tournament
and uh i guess
forget about that journalist that was
that was chopped up by the saudi
government
hey phil give us a wave let's go
yeah
yeah give me a look yes thumbs up
thank you
all right last hour phil mickelson teed
off here we go 16th hole just behind me
here's what happened
[Music]
do it for the saudi royal family
i knew i recognized that voice i knew it
it's jason with the good liar i knew it
did you see the guy in front of him look
at the game in front of him look at the
game in front of you watch watch watch
do it for the saudi royal family
come on man shut the [ __ ] up is what the
guy's standing in front of
him says in the crowd ah come on man
shut the [ __ ] up don't don't point out
stop pointing out that this is all for
the saudis
stop saying that this is a saudi
tournament stop saying that out loud we
don't like to hear we are snowflakes and
we are offended when you tell the truth
[Music]
one more time we will escort you out
okay
i'm sorry one more time one more time
one more time and we'll escort you out
i wish they would have picked him up
right there and took him out that would
have been better for a camera sorry
jason
oh boy sorry
i am sorry i'm very sorry
i'm very sorry
i'm sorry i'm very sorry
the people around him are not are not
amused uh thank you to the good liars
for such a great great reporting there
on the ground
by the way when you uh point out
exactly what phil mickelson is uh
is doing there um here's another great
video from the um
from the saudi tournament i'm not going
to play all of it because it's kind of
weird but that this is the the former
president united states not knowing what
the hell to do when someone starts
singing a patriotic song
not the national anthem i don't maybe he
thinks this is a national anthem like he
knows it's not and then maybe he thinks
it watch what watch what happens
[Music]
god bless america starts right so he's
thinking wait a second is this the
national anthem and he's leaning against
the rail right
he's leaning against the rail and he
thinks oh maybe this is a national
anthem and he's trying to think in his
brain what are you supposed to do during
the national because he knows he can't
sing this he doesn't know the words of
this song but watch
oh yeah put my hand on my heart put my
hand that's that's that's what that's
what that's what a patriot do i don't
want to look like a trader even though i
am a tree's in this piece of [ __ ] so i
put my hand over my heart which that's
what you do during the national anthem i
mean i'm not saying you can't do it
during god bless america
but watch what he does next he realizes
he realizes something
oh [ __ ] i got my hat on oh [ __ ] you're
supposed to take your hat off during the
national anthem
so he takes his head off which is
not a good idea there's a reason why he
has a hat on but watch
you know actually i'm not i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna you know
lie i'm not gonna lie here i actually
think that this hat hair that donald
trump's get that's a much better hairdo
like his hat hair is better than his
actual hairdo i think so
i mean i think it's a little bitter
don't you
i mean he still looks like [ __ ] [ __ ]
but it looks a little better than his
regular haircut that's all i'm saying
and then he taps he taps his heart
because he's getting really bored
and he's like oh my god is it is this i
bless i bless america song over
jesus i mean i know he's singing it for
me but he's tapping his chest
um well it looks like we've yet um
what the hell's going on i think we got
a report from the uh from the new bunker
that's being made
um let's see uh gabe sanchez is
uh gabe how are you
doing pretty good uh uh the the guys
over here are working pretty hard i i
don't know why you're laughing um i i
just i i can't believe how much you've
gotten done uh by this underground
bunker see this place is working 24 7.
soros is pumping a lot of cash into this
project i just want you guys to know
that when the end times does come from a
fascist government through the
republican party
i got a place to go and i've got a
handful of slots for other people too so
we'll figure it out but i'm just letting
you know that we're doing great work
down here uh i'm sure you can hear it in
the background um we can't really hear
it in the background oh you can't well
that must be we just put on some
silencers on top of the jackhammers is
that to not to distract distract
attention from the deep state or what
what is that we don't want to cause uh
too many disruptions
you know for motion sensors you know
people might be thinking oh is that an
earthquake the tectonic plates are
shifting no it's actually soros building
a bunker now again this is an
undisclosed location so once the end
times does come i can take about a
handful of people so
tony you're one of them i don't know who
was jesus christ so here's the thing
folks is uh gabe has uh he's he's has
some jackhammers outside there and and
it i i surmised that it was an attempt
to maybe build his own bunker
um and i i i wanted to we've made a lot
of progress you know you saw me you saw
me over the weekend i was in kind of
like an office space
bunker and now
i'm actually on
the ground site the construction site
building said bunker i just want to give
you guys a you know a snapshot into kind
of what my
day looks like right now so that you
guys know that i'm not just making it up
like there there is a reason why i'm not
on on the show
earlier it was to
uh help you know i'm kind of like the
project manager down here soros thank
you so much for giving me so much
responsibility and trusting me you know
so
oh they they want to know
also are you taking the bros i'm
guessing there's they're saying the
mizellas brothers i guess oh yeah yeah
there's there's a slot for them so i
guess that's it that's that's like the
hand well like there's only there's one
more slot so it's you them three and
then we'll have to maybe we'll do a
raffle or something you know like oh to
see to see who else joins right right
yeah yeah i mean some some people down
here are kind of joking that we're
building
the next noah's ark oh no
yeah that's what they're joking but
i mean we need a lot of space you know
so i don't know how many workers do you
have on that because it looks like
you're kind of lonely there how many
workers do you have well they're they're
in the back they're on uh they're on
break right now having lunch but uh oh i
see i see yeah yeah
but but where where are they uh
uh right now or how many are there um i
would say there's about
i don't know i want to say
uh backwards i don't think so my guy
this is on front words
this is because the back has a as an
adjustment nozzle here so it's now i'm
gonna put it on my forehead unless you
think that the adjustment nozzle is a
third eye but i'm pretty sure
this is the right way
i would know i'm a project manager on a
construction site for a secret
underground bunker that is being
funded by the billionaire left-wing
pro-antifa blm mastermind george soros
so i think i know what i'm talking about
amy amy apologizing
she didn't see the brim so nobody sees
the brim until it's too late and then
i'm right up on onto you and i'm telling
you hey why aren't you building the rest
of that bunker
oh so so
the noise is why you couldn't join us
that well obviously you're working hard
over there yeah
hardly working no i am working hard okay
to get this underground bunker going
yeah um but uh we're we're trying to
pump in through some ac right now we got
some some uh some conduit wire and some
lighting coming through and we've got
you know obviously very important uh
warning you're at a corner right now
you're at a fork in the road if you want
to go right
to uh the rest of the hallway down here
or over here on the hallway so you know
it's a bit of a maze but once you're
down here then you begin to you kind of
you kind of get adjusted to where
you are underground even though you have
no sense of time oh there we go there
are those guys those guys are back like
lunch i guess like they're back from
lunch thank goodness because you know we
got a timeline to meet according to what
george has set for us and obviously you
know this isn't the only bunker we're
building here this is one of several
bunkers we're building this is a deep
state bunker right this is one of the
deep state it is
is this deep steep state one or is this
like deep state 13 how many this is this
is deep state 47. oh there's so we're on
number 47 deep state bunker yep yep i've
been able to get through them by working
on them during the weekends but this
last week we kind of you know we had a
couple things come up some guys had some
birthday parties for their kids they had
to go to so we had to shift around the
schedule so we're going to be working
into this week
well i'm i'm glad you're working hard on
the uh
i mean if
you know then uh or if you can hear me
then i'll stay on the show i see is
anyone else talking about my hat i feel
like people are they keep talking about
my hat are they talking about my hat
well i think well i i think the um
someone else said i have my hat on
backwards and i say
you're wrong
steve steve we've already proven that
guys this is not fake news the hat is
i mean it would be it would be against
deep state regulation if he had it on
backwards right he would definitely look
i prop i i practice proper safety
protocol here in the secret
undisclosed
location for this bunker
and that's that's fantastic i mean look
look if they're
if we don't have safety what do we have
madness we have madness is what it would
be if i was not down here making sure
that we got this bunker finished
on time
well you know i'm glad you guys are
working so hard because republicans
are not working so hard well they might
be working hard to [ __ ] over veterans
well here look democrats are working
hard republicans are hardly working
this is true here is uh john tester he's
a little pissed off he's almost as
pissed off or more pissed off than john
stewart
and gabe let's watch this video of how
he's pissed off that republicans aren't
doing their work the senate doesn't act
and get this bill to the president's
desk we have done this country a big big
big disservice and for those folks out
there and claim their patriots and claim
their wave in the flag damn it back it
up the senate doesn't act
so he's asking he's asking for
republicans to uh to back it up and do
his do their job damn it is what he said
get in there and do your [ __ ] job it
makes sense when you commit to a project
you promise you're going to get
something done on time under budget i
would hope
and you agree that you're going to do it
just like mitch mcconnell agreed to the
face of
of one of his constituents who was a
veteran and said we are going to get
this done and then of course mitch
mcconnell said
psych i'm not actually going to do this
done and it's these people they're
playing politics man they they are on
they're unwilling to do the right good
thing
for another human being right they're
willing to
to say the thing out loud like john
cornyn this weekend literally saying
they were rejecting the pac deck out of
spite
like what kind of representative that
are
back to blue for police law and order
pro-veteran you know let's go to war
hoorah pew pew pew the republican party
will will that quickly just turn their
back and say we don't know you we don't
care for you and we don't care what the
hell you have to say
well i think you actually posted i'm
trying to find it here you actually
posted something about uh yeah here it
is about the corn because he posted
something on twitter about this over the
weekend and you said cornyn and the rest
of the gop believe that messing with
veterans in their healthcare is a game
disgusting they're unwilling to work
like those guys are working so hard
there on that bunker right the president
united states tweeted i plan an
unscheduled trip to capital here this
afternoon to meet with the families
fighting to pass burn pits legislation
he actually popped another positive
covetous because of the the
over-the-counter drugs it it has a
second wave through the pos positive
negative test um
and he points out a positive cova test
got in a way but i wanted to thank
secretary vet of affairs for bringing
pizza in my place so he went in the
secretary of veterans affairs went and
connected with those veterans that are
trying so hard to get republicans like
this [ __ ] box john cornyn to do their
job and vote for this bill
john corden quote tweets the president
united states and here's what he says
here this was what you were responding
to
mr president
passage would have been
not been delayed
if senator schumer had kept his promises
good news is despite that this will pass
next week so what cornyn is saying
gordon is saying here
is that he is getting revenge
they got revenge on schumer yeah and
that's what you're trying to point out
here is that they think it's some kind
of [ __ ] game where they can vote
against it and then vote for it because
they want to prove a point to chuck
schumer not these veterans and they
think you're right
this is high school this is some like
petty way to get back at someone because
oh so and so is dating your ex-boyfriend
or some [ __ ] like that like it's the
dumbest [ __ ] ever right they're coming
after but it's revenge legislation porn
exactly and this is what they're doing
and so they're saying you know what if
you guys didn't do this which again
nothing has changed since they voted on
the same bill on june 16th right like
again and again and again might as touch
has called it out john stewart has
called it out other people in the media
have called it out like the fact that
nothing has changed between how money
was allocated the amount of money that
was allocated and so on and so forth
nothing has changed since june 16th and
now we're all the way at the end of july
we're talking you know august 1st now
and the republican party all of a sudden
decides oh you know what something
changed in here despite that nothing
ever did and so the people that were
voting for it are now voting against it
and ted cruz and mitch mcconnell and all
these other [ __ ] cucks are making it
up to say like oh well the democrats are
trying to sneak one on us nobody did
anything you voted for it and now john
cornyn's saying well if you guys
would've you know schumer would have
agreed to it then well you know what
we'll vote for it next week like like
it's just that easy like you just say oh
you know what this week we're going to
[ __ ] these people over and then next
week yeah sure fine we'll pass it but i
have a feeling like even next week they
might be like oh you guys are trying to
sneak more in again and it's like again
no one is changing anything
oh oh they're definitely gonna they're
definitely gonna play politics with with
veterans health care next week that's
why we have to play politics with the
decisions that republicans are making to
[ __ ] over veterans um you actually uh
posted something here um you posted this
video
of ted cruz
and they're all excited they're really
happy about dude
and you said uh fist me bro ted cruz
probably and i said pound me
josh holly definitely i think that's
what josh hawley's saying here yeah
you know they're willing to throw
someone's life their well-being their
health care
for the sake of
being
right in the situation right they
believe they're right because they think
that something was done nothing nothing
changed nothing was done you know they
voted on this thing they agreed to it
they told people to their face to
veterans faces yes we will pass this
thing for you
and then they said nah
maybe not this week
yeah here's another good example of
imagery here pete
pam keith points us out which group is
actually disrespecting our vets here's a
picture of um
football players jackson
remember how kneeling to
during the national anthem was disre i
mean it was so disrespectful they should
lose their jobs and get kicked off the
field but here you have
united states republican senators
pounding fist in excitement
that veterans will not receive the
health care so i i you know i'm not sure
i think pam points out maybe you should
question yourself which one especially
because you know because you bring up
that photo let's remember that it was a
former green beret
someone from the military who told capp
hey it would be more respectful i
understand what you're trying to do it
would be more respectful if you kneeled
instead of sat that was a green beret a
veteran
a military service member
who told him hey if you want to be
respectful but get your point across
just kneel instead of sit i think that
would be better
speaking of disrespectful traitors um
we had matt gatz
as a feature of alpha cuck yeah speaking
of alpha cucks and traitors he is you
know he got he got cocked bad last week
oh yeah
olivia
olivia
just buried him in cuckness um and i
think she's up to over two million
dollars raised on him on him body
shaming her
yeah i think i think is where she's at
over two million dollars now pretty
impressive i mean there's two million
reasons why matt gates [ __ ] up i mean
right now they're at 2.2 million
dollars 4.2 holy [ __ ] so they're going
to reach they're going to get the 3
million probably by tomorrow
72 hours they were at they were at over
a million and then just 48 hours later
they had hit 2 million so yesterday
uh or two days ago they had hit 2
million and then now they're at 2.2 i
mean they'll hit 2.5
probably in the next day or so right
well who's who who would have known that
matt gatz is one of the best pro
abortion fundraisers that there is
no this is incredible nobody would have
would have uh assumed that you know and
and i i have a i'm working on it today
once i can get away from the
construction site here down to the
bunker i'm gonna kind of house myself
into a more quiet uh surrounding but i
will be working on a what was that that
is dedicated to dragging matt gates
and propping up olivia for the great
work that she has done in this last week
well let's watch this clip because this
clip actually came it got released after
he became the alpha cuck on bonehead of
the week and by the way if you want to
watch bonehead of the week don't forget
to subscribe here on youtube you can
watch it every single sunday in and of
itself you can also with bonehead of the
week you can download in and of itself
on sundays as well on apple spotify
google don't forget to download it there
and if you want to vote for bone end of
the week every single week gabe you can
vote here on youtube
over to twitter
and you can follow at tony michael's pod
and you can vote there for bone end of
the week where you vote you decide we
break it down every friday but this
video i was kind of disappointed this
video came after we did bonehead of the
week yeah i know and this is roger stone
and matt gats what appears to be a
criminal scheme yeah where it makes a
cameo in the what was that i'll tell you
that well it seems that
matt gatz is trying to reassure roger
stone not to flip on trump because trump
will give him a pardon here that's what
it feels like to me let's listen
i'm gonna go i'll go down hard
though he's going to go down on who
i just oh he's going to go down hard
though mean i got it i got it i thought
i thought he was going to go down on
that excuse me i i i miss her get your
money right to the right
and and and that's why i think that this
is a code talk
for
um hey you need to go get me a pardon
because cause
stone can't exactly while he's in this
trial and while he's um under indictment
and in this round that he was in he
can't go appeal to the president himself
or call him on a cell phone i don't
think i think that would be there would
be something to that but he's appealing
to someone who actually has a direct
line to donald trump in that point and
he's saying to the bitter end meaning
until i have to do something that i
don't want to do right which is flip but
let's listen
i may have to appeal to the big man
because
the big man he definitely got the name
right on the head there didn't he though
big i mean he's a big man he's a big man
he's you he's a big dude
he's a big [ __ ] dude
yeah well um here listen to what matt
gant says this
this is all the [ __ ] they say about
hunter biden and and job is all [ __ ]
projected listen they're there i will
say this there is a weird fascination uh
with people like donald trump jr and
matt gates
about their
uh you know accusations
of nepotism
and drug use
and debaucherous activities when they
themselves
are those same products right at least
at least hunter biden said yeah i've got
a problem he went to seek treatment he's
still like if you're if you're an addict
you s that is something you live with
which
experience to me some of the evidence is
pointing to that hunter biden may pay
may pay for some federal crimes i mean i
actually think that's what the memo that
rachel maddow released and everyone
thought it had to do with trump i
actually think it has to do with hunter
biden and joe biden i actually think
that hunter biden is it's a possibility
that he will be charged with federal
crimes i don't know what they are right
i have no idea that's and that's the
that's the biggest difference before
we're going to zoo that's the big
difference between the right and the
left like they're like oh 100 by 100. we
want to investigate let's open an
investigation
okay if you want to do that open
investigation
let's stop talking about it and you guys
can [ __ ] investigate and if you find
something then then we'll charge him and
if he's guilty then he goes to jail like
it's as simple as that right on the flip
side oh matt gates this party of you're
a pedophile and you're a groomer and
you're this and you're that when it
really is them looking at and pointing
themselves in the mirror and saying that
about themselves to say oh actually i'm
the girl i'm the pet like that's what
they're saying as as a republican party
and they're the ones who have this
debaucherous addictive nature and they
are the ones who want to blame others
for it right like it is
it is insane you know and the crazy
thing about this moment right here is
this is matt gates looking out to get
roger stone apart in 2019
when you fast forward to the confession
letter from joel greenberg in 2021 and
he talked about how uh
roger stone was going to sell him a
pardon for 250 dollars right well and
and we know that matt gatz was looking
for a total blanket pardon from that
from the testimony right cassidy
hutchinson from now until the beginning
from the beginning of time up until now
which is a weird thing to ask for
right what do you what do you feel like
is so
serious that you need a pardon to cover
that whole time period like have you
been doing bad crimes this whole time
well what's the deal you know that's the
other thing too here is that the average
american commits federal crimes all the
time they just don't they don't know it
right and really the federal government
doesn't know it because a lot of them
are really minor
um it's something that that you don't
even know really exist inside the law
the and the federal government isn't
willing to expel funds to enforce some
of these you know uh where you're and
i'm not saying like felonies i'm just
talking like even small misdemeanors
people commit them all the time um you
know in just little ways you don't even
know that you're doing it a lot of times
because there's so much to our federal
law and so much to our federal statutes
but you're right matt gatz not only
knows he's committed one crime because
if he knew one crime that he committed
he would be asking for a pardon for that
specifically right that that and also
that right be like in the year 2019 to
2020 i was having sex with minors right
trafficking them again across state
lines like if that's what it is cool but
like we're going from this like i just
want i want to be immune like he was
like all the crimes that i did look i
came out of the womb and i was crying
like that's what he's saying right there
he's like just in case
i want that covered for when i came out
i was crying right well let's listen to
more of the talking about crime here it
really does they really do this this
mobster cosplay that these two are doing
here is really fun
because i got it's the district of
columbia
we surveyed 120 jurors 90 of them know
who i am and they hate my guts
90 of them know who i am so roger stone
is saying here that 120 jurors out of
120 90 of them and know exactly and all
of them all of them like he can't even
get one out of 90 that [ __ ] like
that's how
that's how
like
that is how much of a reputation that
that he has where they're like look
i'm sorry like three-fourths of these
people 90 people like that's enough of a
sample size to get an idea like oh if i
should make this product or not right
but 90 out of 120 people were like
three-fourths of these people said [ __ ]
roger stone
quite impressive right 90 out of 120
know who they are and all of those 90
voluntarily even says that voluntarily
hate his [ __ ] guts which right i mean
it's not hard to do it really i mean
roger stone hasn't made it easy
to like the guy right oh yeah yeah he's
made it really easy to hate his [ __ ]
guts right i mean when you put a tat
back tattoo for uh richard nixon on your
back it's like nah
you're right right you you start to you
start the error on the side to think ah
i'm gonna hate this guy's guts you made
a more permanent decision for people to
say yep got a target on that guy's back
he's an [ __ ]
what an [ __ ] for having a dick on his
back yeah voluntarily
this is 43 seconds later
i don't think the big guy can let
i don't think the big guy that so they
both call him the big guy you know
what's hilarious about this game is in
my comments i don't know for the last
couple [ __ ] years
at least the last six months with this
hunter biden [ __ ] yeah like over and
over and over again they're like oh he
called him the big guy in an email
they're the biden crime family like
and here we are in a situation where
it's not an email it's on [ __ ] tape
where roger stone and matt gets two of
the biggest [ __ ] trumped-up
supporters there are
and they're like man totally ignore that
totally ignore that that's criming yeah
they've said it for months and weeks and
weeks
i mean the thing is matt gates here
stands next to roger stone
you know they're discussing this this
aspect of giving pardons he's like oh
the big guy thinks highly or i think in
the other the audio clip he says the big
guy is thinking highly you know and then
he's like oh i do i think he calls in
the boss and the right the boss right
right and you know they're going back
and forth and they're saying you know
you know i i do have to come with him
from time to check in with him from time
to time where he says that from time to
time or whatever it might be like these
guys especially matt gates is trying to
act like a goddamn mobster
he's like oh dude i'm the right hand man
of the godfather i kissed that ring and
he respects me right it's mobster
first [ __ ] person to get your knees
capped and put in a ditch of a of a
cornfield that's your character
or a ditch of betminster maybe i don't
know i'm just oh yeah well or or the
idea that this guy
will be like oh dude i am you know he's
the first to go he is the first person
on the list when when the feds come in
and and flip this big man the the boss
right as a
as a ci for the feds
they he goes okay well you you need to
give us someone and he goes okay cool
matt gates easy like that's the first
one he's gonna get
joel greenberg has already done that and
i i actually believe the reason why the
feds in that case haven't moved
on
matt getz is because of some of this
audio right here these because roger
stone and matt gatz are tied deep into
that greenberg case and i believe that
the feds are questioning rather donald
trump gave these [ __ ] idiots some
sort of pocket pardon that the courts
may honor if they charge them with
federal crimes and the grand jury
indicts him but let's listen to the
audio part that washington post released
it's about just over 30 seconds long he
calls him medkits calls him the boss in
this
[Music]
that
and
the boss still has a very stable
the boss still has a very favorable view
of you yeah what the [ __ ] what i mean
literally they they can't help but
cosplay mobsters
like it is it is [ __ ] weird man
this is really weird stuff
again you know matt gates thinks he's
some macho guy remember matt gates is
the he is the product of nepotism from
his father don gates who was the state
the florida state senate president
down in the panhandle
he comes and and he also takes over his
district as well and and takes his seat
in 2016.
but the idea here that matt gates is
some sort of [ __ ] macho man that he's
some sort of bro that he's like oh i
know exactly what's going on i got the
ear to trump and i'm kissing that ring
and he's the godfather and i'm the
right-hand man and i will do anything
and this guy loves me more than he loves
his son don don jr which of course he
doesn't love his son don jr so that's a
metric there but he's saying like oh i
am the guy that trump will rely on and
trust
to give him the news and deliver the
news
and again matt gates is not that guy he
is the first one to go the first one to
be given up
for anyone like oh [ __ ] that matt gates
guy i hate that guy he's terrible he's a
[ __ ] dude he's a dick he's a prick
he's an [ __ ] he will be the first one
to be given up
to to to any sort of law enforcement
when someone's like we need to negotiate
a deal and he's like all right fine here
speaking of uh negotiating deals why
they're why the republicans are still
trying to negotiate to change the pact
act
on how to cap the funding
um
[Music]
kelly mayer here is reporting
veterans and advocates tell me two
veterans
that they know of have already died by
suicide since the pacnack was blocked um
very sad stuff
republicans definitely have blood on
their hands and it's not just one
one portion of america
um they want to strike fear
and heartache in the hearts of all
americans they think that's their way to
this fascist state that they have
by making veterans fear if they'll have
health care not to fear if they'll
um if they can rely on the government
that's that's what this is and that's
what it's going to continue to be
so we need to pass the pact act now
right now
um so anything you can do uh get on the
phone uh
light up the switchboards in washington
right now
um get on and support some of these
veterans groups that are standing
outside the capitol
um you know whatever you can do to help
get the pack act pass i think i think uh
schumer plans on bringing this to the
floor
now let's see if we can see if he's made
statements
uh let me see
if i can find
i know he said the other day he was um
here we go this was uh yesterday he said
he was uh let's see if i can bring this
up on the screen here
i'm standing with uh new york veterans
to announce that despite the gop effort
to prevent the pack act passing last
week
there'd be a new senate vote this week
our veterans who got sick from toxic
exposure in the line of duty must get
the health care they need deserve and
that's that's the craziest part about
this about this whole thing i think
gabe is that
these veterans
were put in a situation where they were
near or in these burn pits right
following orders doing their job
of disposing of material
inhaling these fumes and that's what's
caused them um to have these illnesses
especially because republicans
republicans are like oh thank you for
your service we're so grateful for you
giving your life they are your country
or not they are and within the same
breath they'll be like oh you know what
you go [ __ ] yourself i mean you know jon
stewart called it out he was talking
about the uso and he was talking about
the bags that were made you know in the
care packages and i think it was
uh was rick scott right who was there
and yeah he was calling him out and he's
like oh you know you know there's one
there's eminems in that in that right
it's like they'll they'll tweet about
this to be like oh i'm so grateful for
the for our armed services and those
people who are veterans and we're making
these care packages and it's like oh
that's that's the extent that you will
go to actually give back to the people
that you
said you were grateful for
that were protecting this country
it's despicable it's despicable and and
they don't give a [ __ ] not just about
veterans if if they're willing to turn
their backs on veterans as much as they
they they [ __ ] act like they sent for
them
and they sent for veterans they'll turn
their back on average americans in a
heartbeat
100
and really honestly i believe that
republicans are probably excited that
there's two less veterans here that the
government has to that the government
has to pay for or think about like these
are real these are real people
with real lives
and this has real consequences
and like you know i know that we joke
around in the show and stuff like that
but this is a real problem right now
these are these are representatives
these are senators that have come
forward and told people to their face
that they would protect them that they
that they admire them that they're
grateful for them that they care for
them that they will do anything in their
power to make sure that they get back
what they gave to us
and in the flip of a switch
they say nah [ __ ] it you're gone i don't
care about you
just like i mean like you said it
earlier show they're anti everything
republicans are anti-american they don't
care about you they only care about
themselves
and the checks that go into their
pockets from the lobbyists here is a
veteran outside the step of the capital
let's hear it in his words abilities uh
including respiratory issues
from being in the desert
i'm actually out here with my wife and
daughter and a bunch of veterans who are
trying to bring light to the fact that
24 republicans specifically republicans
blocked the pac pact act
i mean i'm also out here for my friends
i have friends i have a friend who has
two kinds of cancer in his tongue and in
his throat he has three kids
and a spouse i have a friend who has
multiple tumors
all over his body from being in from
getting into toxic waste from the
soviets in bagram air base
i have a friend who has esophageal
asthma
from being in
around burn pits in baghdad
i have a friend who lost a third of his
body weight because he got into
some sort of toxin in the desert and
came back and immediately got extremely
ill
and is still ill
and i'm out here
a friend who was in
the first gulf war who has
polyps all over his lungs and has copd
and
we you all need to call your senators
immediately specifically the 24
republicans
that block this bill
and they need to get their butts down
here tomorrow so there you have it from
a veteran on the steps of the capitol
fighting for not just him and his family
but other families and other friends
that have suffered
from illnesses by
patriotically serving their country
following orders and doing their duty
and us as americans owe it to them to
give them the decency of health care so
just what he said call those 24
republican senators [ __ ] those guys [ __ ]
them call them pound their phones light
the goddamn boards up
and until tomorrow because you know we
will broadcast here tomorrow and i'm not
going to stop talking about this until
they vote for this pack act until
tomorrow
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head